this video is sponsored by brilliant a
simple pendulum a planet orbiting a star
two balls colliding if you've studied
physics at school chances are you're
familiar with these kinds of systems
you've describe the position of each
element in the system with a number or
several numbers and the change in those
numbers is their velocity this works
very well for these kinds of systems but
there's a whole world of things you
can't describe this way because how do
you apply this kind of maths to say
flowing water what about fluids
scientists including Archimedes Da Vinci
and Newton as well as presumably some
people who weren't white dudes but the
history books never mention studied the
physics of fluids but it wasn't until
1739 at the publication of hydrodynamica
by Daniel benui that we started using
mathematics to describe fluids since
1739 their physics have become better
and better understood with key
contributions coming from Claude Louis
navier and George Gabriel Stokes whose
work together produced this beautiful
equation describing how any fluid flows
you learn to love it and one of the
reasons you learn to love it is because
this amazing equation has applications
that go from a droplet of water to our
entire galaxy I was introduced to the
physics of flow mechanics during my time
studying at Oxford specifically I fell
in love with the maths of fluids in the
library at Saint Peter's College over a
decade ago but there was another
location super significant in my
Personal Learning Journey and that is
right here I think actually under this
exact Tree in Christchurch Meadows in
Oxford it was here in 2011 that I sat
and compiled some very early notes on
what fluid mechanics was based on the
lecture notes I had to date and the
textbook I sat here by the river
discovering a whole new way I could use
mathematics to describe the world to
describe this very River in fact and in
retrospect it was one of those moments
that completely changed the course of
the rest of my life and the concept that
did it was fluid elements you've almost
certainly heard that we can divide Mata
into solids liquids and gases yes there
are more states of matter but that's a
video for another time most of the time
you will be dealing with solid matter or
fluid matter on a molecular level a
solid is a substance in which molecules
or atoms are tightly packed and
crucially interact with one another
strongly this is typically through
electromagnetic forces between electrons
and neighboring molecules or atoms these
forces keep the structure of a solid
quite rigid by contrast a fluid can have
molecules quite close to one another but
they don't interact strongly in water
for example electrons in neighboring
molecules don't directly interact but
they're charged within a single water
molecule is unevenly distributed more
positive on one side of the molecule
more negative on the other these charged
dipoles in each molecule exert a weaker
electromagnetic force on each other
these weaker forces between molecules in
fluids means that they can move around
more freely and so a gas or a liquid
will deform easily when an external
force is applied in contrast to a solid
which won't now you might think to
yourself fine why is this interesting
you Big Nerd because while this may
sound Niche systems of large numbers of
weekly interacting objects are
everywhere from inside my body to the
planet that I'm living on and Beyond but
in order to understand those things we
need a special piece of maths and this
is where a fluid element comes in it's
if you like a small parcel of a fluid
imagine keeping track of this square of
molecules as Time Marches On the fluid
in that square is deformed by the flow
and it changes shape and size all the
molecules originally in the Square are
still there they're just spread out in a
different shape the important thing is
that a fluid element has enough
molecules in it to be in the Continuum
limit what that means is that instead of
considering a bunch of individual
molecules we can average what they're
doing in a meaningful way for example
every molecule has a certain kinetic
energy we say that the temperature of an
object is the average kinetic energy of
a molecule in that object but that
average doesn't mean much if there are
say three molecules we need more like
thousands or Millions for the average to
be meaningful mathematically we require
that n l cubed is much greater than one
where n is the number density in other
words how many objects there are per
unit volume on average and L is the
rough scale of the system we're
considering basically are we looking at
millimeters or kilometers there's a
balancing act here we require that our
fluid element is large enough that it
contains enough molecules to have
averages that are physically meaningful
but also small enough that there are no
significant variations in it of a
variable of interest like say
temperature when you can satisfy both of
these properties you can do some really
interesting Maths for example you can
isolate a section of fluid and consider
the forces acting on it which we can
assume to have single values a section
of fluid with density rho acted on by
net force F will experience an
acceleration as per Newton's second law
however this gives us an acceleration
relative to that fluid element which may
itself also be moving and deforming we
refer to this rate of change of
something in or of a fluid element as
the material or lagrangian derivative
and sometimes we are interested in that
derivative but more often than not we're
interested in what's going on in a fixed
coordinate system like what's happening
relative to a box that the fluid is in
what we call the eulerian derivative
fortunately these two derivatives can be
related really quite easily the material
derivative is the eulerian derivative
but with some extra accounting on the
end just to do with how the fluid
element is moving around
don't worry about it applying that to
Newton's Second Law acting on a fluid
element gives us an equation that
describes how fluid moves in a box or
anywhere else you'd like to put a fluid
you can see that this is basically where
the navier stotes equation comes from
but with a few extra bits
don't worry about it one of the obvious
ways we can apply these ideas is to
water we can for example look for the
steady state solution meaning it doesn't
change over time for water flowing down
a cylindrical pipe the equation for
acceleration in the reference frame of
the pipe given a pressure p forcing
water down the pipe looks like this we
can solve it by assuming that the water
molecules at the very edges must be
stationary what we call the no slip
condition and voila you recover the
speed of the water at different
distances away from the pipe wall but
that's a super simple example you can
also use these equations to describe how
water flows around the world's oceans
and how it transports heat and salt
during my degrees I learned about the
many applications of these equations to
fluids on Earth perhaps most obviously
you can describe the atmosphere using
these equations calculating how it will
flow in response to energy coming in
from the Sun this is how weather
forecasts are made but you don't need to
stop there the same equations can be
applied to atmospheres on other planets
for example explaining Jupiter's bands
of clouds or Saturn's hexagonal polar
vortex or I learned you could go deeper
and model the movement of the Earth's
molten interior using the exact same
equations but here's the thing about
learning Journeys they don't end since
my degree I've learned so much more
about physics and about how Universal
some of the concepts are when I was last
here I experienced a conceptual
Revolution about how you can use
mathematics to describe the world around
us to describe water and the atmosphere
but that's not all you can do with that
maths since then I've learned that you
can apply those same ideas that same
fluid maths to Stars and I don't just
mean describing the internal dynamics of
stars yes you can use fluid math for
that sure but you can also use the same
ideas to describe how stars move within
a Galaxy instead of considering
molecules making up a droplet of water
we can consider Stars making up a Galaxy
because both are formed of large numbers
of individual components that are tiny
compared to the whole and that weakly
interact with one another
electromagnetically in one case and
gravitationally in the other
mathematically they're very similar but
you may say water molecules are way more
tightly packed than stars are in a
galaxy and you'd be right the average
separation of water molecules is about a
nanometer which isn't much bigger than
the size of a water molecule and while
Stars can be millions of kilometers
across they are on average millions of
millions of kilometers apart however
let's go back to our definition of a
fluid element we require that the number
of objects in our element is much
greater than one and if we select say
one millionth of the volume of our
galaxy on average there will be more
than a hundred thousand stars in that
volume more than enough to satisfy the
averaging requirements for fluid
mechanics the difference between a
Galaxy and say water is instead that the
constituent object of a galaxy don't
frequently collide with each other thank
God while water molecules do so we draw
a distinction between Collision null and
collision lust fluids in a collision
novel fluid we can define a pressure due
to the constant collisions of
neighboring objects like molecules in
water and we can relate that pressure to
the density of the system by what we
call an equation of State in a collision
less fluid you can't do either of those
things so instead of considering a
pressure being the force acting on a
fluid element in a galaxy we instead
consider how gravity created by star
Mars changes throughout a Galaxy apart
from that though the mathematical ideas
are basically the same we treat the
Galaxy as being a smoothly varying
Continuum and can follow the trajectory
of an individual fluid element or even
an individual star or the evolution of
the whole system over time and we
observe behaviors that we typically
associate with fluid flows on Earth such
as chaos the evolution of a single star
through a Galaxy especially in
configurations like a spiral arm can be
turbulent and chaotic no not that kind
of Galactic chaos one particularly cool
thing this allows you to do is measure
where stars are and how fast they're
moving today and then apply our fluid
equations to that system but instead of
going forwards in time turn the clock
back we can guess what the Galaxy looked
like a hundred years ago and then using
that as a starting point we could apply
our equations again and guess what the
Galaxy looked like 200 years ago keep
going backwards and you can perform
Galactic archeology reconstructing in
the Deep past of the Galaxy spoiler
alert using this technique we know that
at some point in the distant past the
Milky Way collided with another galaxy
and for more about that you can watch
the video I made with a student at the
University of Cambridge studying his PhD
in Galactic archeology another very cool
application of this technique is in Dark
Matter research because it turns out
that the gravity created by stars isn't
enough to explain how galaxies behave
you need to add the Gravity from some
stuff that we can't see dark matter how
much of it and where it is are questions
that can be interrogated by modeling the
Galaxy and the dark matter as a fluid
but why stop at a Galaxy this is where
things get really mind-blowing because
galaxies themselves are formed into
clusters and super clusters each
containing tens or hundreds of thousands
of galaxies and the way that those
galaxies formed into clusters is studied
using fluid mechanics it's another
system that satisfies our requirement
moments for a fluid element just this
time the constituent objects themselves
galaxies are also modeled as fluid
systems from Galaxy clusters to galaxies
to Stars themselves its fluids all the
way down we're actually weird because we
can't be described as a fluid although
what a lot of us can be what I'm getting
at in this video is that the ideas of
fluids the mathematics of fluids are
Universal they apply at the tiniest
humblest scales and also on the scale of
the observable universe so I suppose
that means that what I'm really getting
at is that physics is awesome to me
physics is beautiful physics strips away
the surface details and renders the
world in abstract relationships and the
more you look the more you find the same
relationships
everywhere this river that I sat next to
all those years ago and made my notes on
fluid mechanics is governed by those
equations the same equations that govern
how R star moves around our galaxy and
how our galaxy moves around the universe
and if you don't think that's cool
don't worry about it when was the last
time you thought about Newton's Second
Law you might still be in school and so
it might have been yesterday or it could
have been years or even decades as I
said earlier learning Journeys are
lifelong but they don't have to be
formal and they certainly don't have to
be expensive or boring if you would like
to learn about topics in physics
chemistry maths or computer science
whether you're at school or haven't
thought about Newton's laws in 20 years
brilliant is a free and easy way to do
so and they've kindly sponsored this
video brilliant has thousands of lessons
covering the basics right the way up to
Advanced topics and they're adding new
lessons every single month as you've
already seen these lessons are
beautifully Illustrated and crucially
they're interactive the whole point of
brilliant is to get you actively
involved in your learning and that means
you choosing the topics that you are
interested in studying but also getting
you to apply your knowledge as soon as
you learn it and if you get something
wrong as brilliant stresses that's
healthy part of a learning process and
wouldn't you know it they have lessons
on Newton's Laws as part of their cause
on classical mechanics in bite-sized
chunks of 15 minutes a day you can
support your learning in the classroom
or be introduced to cool new Concepts
like relativity to get started learning
about the world around you free for a
full 30 days visit brilliant.org Simon
Clark or click the link in the
description and the first 200 of you to
do so will also get 20 off brilliant's
annual premium subscription that's
brilliant.org Simon Clark with thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video and
for continuing to be well
brilliant thank you so much for watching
I really hope that you enjoyed this
video huge thanks must go to my patreon
supporters these are the names of my
lovely executive producer patrons my
executive producers and my producers
picked this video topic for this month
and I just want to say thank you because
I had a blast making this video this is
the kind of thing that I wish I could do
more of So yeah thank you for letting me
do this if you would like to support my
work and get access to exclusive content
and have a say in what videos get made
then you can check out a link to my
patreon in the description what do you
think is the coolest application of
fluid mechanics I can guarantee that
there are tons of systems that I've
never heard of so please let me know
about your cool application of this
maths down there in the comments if you
enjoyed the video please do pop it a
thumbs up and do share it with people
that you think may find it interesting
if you'd like to watch something else
then here's some of my previous videos
and that just leads me to say thank you
again for watching I'll see you in the
next one